hello guys I'm Greg with the lovely say
your [ __ ] name indeed uh I need a
anita star Tyrone Magnus actually
introduced us
he said that we lived in the same city
Beverly Hills that's right
three-story mansion Anita has her own
channel
Anita star and she has some really funny
videos on there and John I actually just
did a video with her you guys should go
check it out he's it it's not one of
those boyfriend does makeup videos
that's a video on my channel and yeah
John and I were the voices for it I Nina
and I are in a serious committed
relationship now thanks to Tyrone
yes this is the sign of a serious
committed relationship yes all the way
so I just want to tell Tyrone it back
off and quit saying you're gonna make
sex videos with her today we're going to
watch it should I not the last challenge
by a tick the one or a dick the one a
dick the one so many people said if
you're going to do try not to laughs you
should do this guy I've never done
eternal - laughs well it's very simple
it's exactly why reaction channels have
so much respect it's because of hard
work that life is these videos that have
so much content Patrick
babies I know doing it all wrong all we
have to do Anita is try not to laugh
okay whatever you do try not to let's
try not to laugh and I like to add the
exo doesn't say in the title but I like
it when you're not supposed to even
smile yeah weird right that's a lot of
added pressure don't smile everyone I
know Wendy ready Anita I'm ready sir go
[Music]
I left Syria
[Music]
wearing a super cute dress today but it
doesn't have any pockets so where is the
question I can just wear it and I've
gotten to play with this hand tablet
I've been working at take you into the
normal kitty but it's I need to I can
fold it up Dominic - your friend goes
ooh oh yeah
[Music]
how much coming of years
yes we're what fair line ranks first
with seven special on all North American
Airlines but you know what rank least in
santa section nine eleven airlines well
that's terrible name for an airliner
lend me the tragedy of 9/11
[Music]
well the movie really is amazing my
girls are completely engrossed by it
when we're watching it because it really
does make you feel like you're inside
this 11 year old girl any her family
wholesome way some are huge the small
one one folks say shuns gangsta is
missing your slider just give money
there's no tummy oh my god what is that
wrong
yeah what the [ __ ] hell is the [ __ ]
is that we shoot we ain't never seen the
clubhead oh my god man we are seeing
some [ __ ] me never seen before what is
that [ __ ] thing - nothing looks hurt
that thing is big yeah we could do all
on my god look at this thing
oh my look at this holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
Jay oh my god oh man we need to [ __ ]
go get that [ __ ] rope oh man
G then he's a [ __ ] Smith the tunable
actual along in image oh we doin what's
honorable of thing I'd like to do is
imagine my money related stress is the
most disgusting terrifying creature I
can think of
ask me to imagine him an ugly greasy
little creature with a hooked nose and
oily black homey atmosphere I Colin
McNabb because he's a 3d little monster
and wants to collect all my money in the
close your eyes and picture the grappler
girls area because all the problems your
grabber is causing he invented interest
rates like the ones on your credit card
he's taking the job because grabbers
only hire their own kind I just only get
right now imagine the grappler slowly
disintegrating like this right olive
ashes blown away by a purifying wind and
now you're in a peaceful nettles
chemically swaying and a gentle breeze
they're not seeming you're trying to
oh that really works whoa what a week Oh
drums president have is our first video
[Music]
[Music]
you're welcome indeed you're welcome 8
into 1 ok so I can recall like three
times there really laughs yeah
the reverse when the goddess would be a
Dark Knight 1 yeah right on buddy
yeah I was doing perfect so I wasn't
expecting that at all I think the
funniest ones were like when they when
they slice it with something I was
familiar with like a dark night or the
the 1-800 Empire one was really funny
something really funny weird you know
we're kind of disturb me yeah it was
like is this real or I mean I think
that's part of the the great thing about
a try not to watch like one of these I
could see why it is do so well it is
only a lot of you he knows how to mix it
up with one ok this one won't be so
funny right you can be a little bit
unexpected yeah that's a good at you in
a certain mode and I think he knows what
a huge exposure you knows how to talk
away with your emotions yeah [ __ ] a
dick may be different in the 8th right
in the ages yeah yeah well welcome to
the first video you've been on the real
nature I think I mean it's very
challenging stuff it is Thank you very
Dunning down your content for me to be
on your channel normally I like to have
really strong you know I want to watch
the bracket ribbing stuff yeah the
little get as many views oh well damn as
I try not to laugh challenge will I
actually thoroughly enjoyed that
challenge I enjoyed it and believe it or
not I could say whatever I want about
reaction channels including this one and
those people have already clicked off
now the reaction die hey it's done yeah
sure I'm passionate about doing try
knots a lot challenges and what reactor
isn't
are you still nervous of being here you
make me nervous great idea of presence
in general is the sexuality before I
give up actually just like this you
should I sit like this for the rest of
the media turn around and just like
twerk a little bit oh yeah maybe I
should just bend over and you can can i
what something something sexual I'll
have to do it right yeah that's what I
was going for there gosh I was like I
don't have anything witty yeah I did it
shower right now she was sleeping in my
bed after we arrived you know taking a
break after the mad crazy sex is the
hard intercourse yeah it was very hard
so eNOS was fully erect Ophidian oh and
my vagina was wet like can't eat raw
liver oh yeah yeah wake up like someone
crash into a fire hydrant
that's all right motion below click off
by this point if your hands you can
subscribe to the real rejects subscribe
Anita star please watch her channel
there Russia sitting really funny videos
I was like see what I wrote on that
watches my videos I'm white I am your
most consistent viewers and I am awesome
you have some idea a few alright you do
that little YouTube heart they are yeah
I look like my you are president if it
happened how to you know shut up you
know you love your rejects I do I'd love
my reject me and I love my stargazers we
can love our [ __ ] sub Greg yeah
great really close to each others face
it's just like put some your to things
not did you really have coffee breath
and I didn't want to like Bialik
invasive in your [ __ ] you know them
standard if I look in my head I am disco
G we are going to some lips will shot
you'll and we love all the rest of the
night I'll never get my chicken ml thank
ya